[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
how's everything buddy buddy how you
doing good man you know just drinking
i'm still
still still drinking this uh tequila
that's
it do you ever chase gin no taste gin
no but my pine soul really like
turpentine like something weird
i have an aunt mayan eileen who shouted
and eileen
only drinks gin and tonics and black
coffee so i'll i'll
most of the time say to a bartender if i
want a gin and tonic i'll let me get an
eileen or black coffee i'll say give me
an eileen and then what do they do to
you no i'll only say it around other
family members to make them laugh
so they know it goes over because
usually they'll be like you know the
waiter and
they'll be like what are you talking
about yeah like what i don't know we
don't have that i'll say oh it's a
ginger
but have you ever had gin without any
even like juice
or tonic or anything like that numb it's
rough
rough rough really rough rough no i'm
not
a big alcohol guy i drink white wine i
drink a lot of pinot grigio beer
oh by the way not a big drinker either i
had a friend one of my friends came from
san diego last week um and we went out
and drank
i got sal annihilated
annihilated me carry me
yes yes i was last week yeah last week
you're dabbling in boot drinking yeah as
soon as as soon as um
uh cuomo opened it up governor cuomo
here twenty-five percent you're ready
for the boot went right through the boot
i dash boot up i was eating pretzels
forget about my fitness but i deleted i
threw my phone off the frickin varazano
because it had my fitness pal in it i i
full treating it much like a pal no i
know i know you ready for what i what i
took down i'm ready two two
boots of beer two boots pizza shout out
two boots of beer
you're just drinking massive amounts of
beer
two humongous pretzels with mustard so
it's relatively healthy
a nutritionist told me once every day
what you gotta have mustard
kale hibiscus tea those three things
he said those three things you'll lead a
very healthy life what are the
properties of mustard
i don't know but he said if you have
mustard kale and hibiscus tea
you go three for three you you forget
about anything else
you do whatever a mustard kiln hibiscus
tea smoothie every morning that's what
he said
yep mustard contains antioxidants you
ready for what i had though
three beers yeah the boot or two two dos
boots
and then a baby beer two humongous
pretzels
schnitzel and you know what i ended it
with oh you had a german spot
you know what i ended it with yeah
french onion soup at the german place
what was your toilet looking like that
later that day as tim dillon would say
not good
then i get home at night i get home and
by the way it's not even at night it's 8
30 p.m
get home i'm drunk as a skunk so it's
obvious like my girlfriend's you know
you know
when you come home drunk as a skunk even
though it's funny it's like you know we
got two kids it's like
what are you doing here were you able to
get some your
mind over matter and act not drunk or
could you not even
hide it and you were acting drunk when
you got home i literally
i i was i'm talking about fall down
yelling drunk the first thing i did is i
walked right in i didn't even say hello
to my family they were watching tv they
turn around i'm walk
right into my daughter's room and i get
her stuffed animals
i just gotta stuffed animals i sat on
the couch laughing hysterically at
nothing
yeah they were watching twilight saga
eclipse i'm hysterically laughing
at twilight for no reason having a great
time jasmine's like you're
drunk you need to go take a shower and
uh of course you're sponsoring your
drunkes no you go take a shower
yeah that's what you said why do you
need to take a shower who knows let's
open you up
sober you open up a cold shower and she
was just like you stink
right oh so you know stink like alcohol
whatever and i'm like i'm sorry you know
i'm telling everybody i love them you
know
you know um um it's unbelievable yeah so
and then i stay on social medias when
you're not drunk i i will tweet to
i'll tex i texted homeless pimp logged
me out i'll always post log me out
you said you said that you said you're
going to get so drunk tonight yes
that you're going to stay off i was like
why do you get why are you saying this
because i knew how bad it was going to
get because i haven't seen this guy in a
year
okay and then it got bad and then when
you know what i did last minute move i
uber each
uber 8. what do you say i uber eats it
yeah
uber i uber eats yeah you carvel you
braid it you ubereated carvel
yeah you know what i went in for ready
for our old pal cinnabon i went in for
900 calories cinnabon at 9 30 at night
with a large carvalanch reese's peanut
butter car valence like an avalanche but
from carvalho i've never heard of
carving lance
were you born and raised are you a
russian are you working for the russian
government
you've never heard you don't know that
cinnabun engineer and you've never heard
of a carvalhan
no i i could tell you all about carvel i
grew up with carvel we filmed the carvel
carville has a flying saucer what do you
mean you filmed what do you what else do
you do
i'm on a cable access show oh all right
maybe yeah okay
no no the flying saucer right and then
they have the cookie puss
that's shout out cookie [ __ ] god fudgie
the whale fudge am i cheating on my girl
if i'm getting some cookie puss i don't
think so
that's good thank you see i told you it
wasn't cheating sounds like those cones
dipped in chocolate that it hardens up
the sherry bonnet
what it's a bonnet cherry bonnet is that
cherry that's called the bonnet
isn't that called the bonnet when they
dip the cone in in the chocolate and it
hardens
magic free yeah
a cherry bomb i think it's called a
brown bonnet a brown bond and a cherry
bonnet oh wow i didn't
absolutely let's go through carville i'm
john bonitoni
look at that oh now i want carvel
now i want clock out order it order it
i got news for you kids i'm getting kind
of drunk again
when i get drunk it's time to uber eats
carvel
you know the theme song birth control
control
the theme song no carville
fresh no i don't know ice cream
no i don't know i don't know i know i i
i don't know that
okay um what am i gonna do what what can
you do what can i do about it
you know i mean i know other jingles by
man and we said that one yeah we did
this one yeah what about um
just real quick um what can you think of
real quick
quick food jingle quick food jingle can
you take them do you remember the songs
of uh the song
of the supermarket food emporium located
here in
new york city uh someone made a store
just for me you don't know that food
emporium food emporium
oh yeah someone has my kind of quality
food emporium food important everyone
got the message
that people like things better
especially when they're shopping for
the finer things something like that wow
pull it up
oh we can't we can't play that oh we
can't play it huh i mean come on what is
going on with this country
we're gonna get flagged if we play it
we're gonna get flagged i'll give them a
freaking flag
we got to monetize for a clip of you on
jokers
we got demonetized for that one video
well how am i supposed to buy the house
we got to monetize for my own clip i own
the clip
[Music]
who do i got to talk to about that i'm
demonetizing myself it's like an
autoimmune deficiency
that's what it is you're you're the
lupus i was going to say you lupus
that's what that's called now we're
calling sal lupus
on the show called lupus more today than
yesterday b-o-l-o-g-n-a oh b-o-l-o-g
you ready for this what i'm about to
tell you and i swear to god it's this is
the god's honest truth please
i've never in my life had a piece of
baloney
what the [ __ ] are you crazy
i've never in my life had a piece of as
a slice of bologna and you don't think
that's odd
you're curious i think i personally have
bologna curious
not having i think that i think it's
equal i think me never having a piece of
bologna is
as odd as you not thinking that
cinnabuns were within walking distance
of your house in new york city
well you think that those are on the
same level pam
what do you say where the nearest
cinnabon establishment is to me
but you have 36 years of not chewing on
a piece of by the way i don't even know
if the cinnabon episode came out yet so
if
you don't know what we're talking about
just wait a week it might not have right
it might not if it depends on the
bologna and cheese sandwich
never in my life you know what i you
know what one thing i do i don't like
cold cuts
i don't need cold cuts i don't really
like cold cuts i've had turkey and
cheese but
you've you've had you've had every cold
cut except for bologna
and liverwurst never had liverwurst or
bologna or olive oil
i've never had olive oil what are you
saying liverwurst liverwurst
spells
yeah yeah olive oil the only reason i've
had these things is that i worked at a
deli for four years
right and i tried them and liverwurst
liverpool what do you say
livervist liverwurst yeah is grass
grunt how many people in the deli be
honest with me
how many people daily or weekly came in
and ordered
a liverwurst sandwich or an olive loaf
sandwich we got about like
one a week one liverwurst olive off same
person the liverworts people we hated
them you know why
why as soon as you cut liverwurst you
have to clean the entire machine why
because the consistency of liverwurst
would get like it would just get like
this it would smudge and not come off
it wouldn't come off so if i if you're
backed up if you're backed up i mean you
got you're you're
you've got it's lunch time it's a lunch
there has been times there there could
have been feasible amount of times in my
life where i've been waiting on a 30
minute line for my lunch order because
somebody ordered a deliverance and
people have to stop down
and then you take it
no it's pretty well you take a rag and
you get it real hot and soapy and then
you turn the machine on
you clean it as best you can it's
terrible there's chunks of old
stuff in there and then it it builds up
right away it's everything between
cheese and meats and hams and
right or everything it's just but then
but the little you have to push
the rag you push it on the blade i mean
you could do it different ways but
i will start the blade and then very
carefully
push the rag onto the side of the blade
and then it would just clean itself as
long as you put enough pressure
you you it was it was and i was just
like a teen i was a
a hot young teen only you could get an
hype
you see that tip on my fingers yeah i
cut it off on the slicer
cut really yeah and it grew back it was
like i would say like 10
15 percent of the tip of my finger so
you so you if i went like that you would
see like a slope and
right the finger was gone i did it i
know exactly who how
who i did it for too woman used to come
in without them out them i don't know
her name
but she used to come in and she always
used to get a 12-pack of bud
for her husband because he really liked
to hit the sauce that's that's what she
says but it could have been that thing
that we said where
she's ordering for someone but it's
really her she's got the alcohol but he
used to come in and she had a kid
and needs to come in after school she
used to always get a 12 pack of bud and
one day she told me to order
she wanted pepperoni pepperoni wasn't
the order that we got a lot of right
and pepperoni we had a stick that was
like that thick only
so she wanted me to slice pepperoni thin
so i was just like [ __ ] and i did it
slicing pepperoni because it's like it's
so little that you have to hold it
and i just it all it took in five years
there only cut myself once on the slicer
but all it took
was just a moment of like not paying
attention
did you get blood on the pepperoni i
didn't i no
there was no blood at first i looked at
it there was no blood it was just
cut so much the blood it was so fast the
blood didn't come out yet
and then it stung and hurt like a
shooting pain and then all of a sudden
you saw dots forming and then all of a
sudden it just started bleeding
everywhere i wrapped it in a towel
they took me to the emergency room and
they you had to go to the emergency room
yeah i had to i sliced my finger off
and they put it in i remember they put
it in iodine i believe why
what does it have to do i guess it
sterilizes it or something wow
i don't know it burns people cut their
fingers off on these machines all the
time right
i'm not the authority but i mean i would
say i would say about 30 000 people
about 30 000 people both kids and adults
are rushing all over it
because they've amputated a finger the
two most common causes are from things
many of us come into contact with every
day doors and power tools
would you consider a cold cutting
machine a power tool yeah i suppose i
would yeah
yeah by the way my girlfriend today we
built a shelf
and it's gotten to the point now where
she jus i'm just the holder
she just asked me to hold stuff and she
comes out with the she's six months
pregnant
with the drill drilling stuff you know
uh screws in her mouth
and she's just like then she did a demo
she did a demonstration for me today and
behind me like wearing ghost and held
her hand over my hand
and held and showed me how to screw
screws in and i was just like this is
the most emasculating thing
of all time i i'll tell you right now uh
the stuff i hung up in this house
yeah i feel like the first two years i
didn't have anything hanging up
i had to like get help like you didn't
you couldn't even hang this up
we hung this up well the thing was
already in there i hung that free once i
once i realized like someone like my i
think my dad came here with like a
package of like things he's like yeah
just put this into the wall this is 20
pounds 30 pounds 100 pounds yeah and he
helped me but like my last place before
this
my dad hung everything for me really
yeah but it's more that my dad can build
a house from scratch
he really can actually but it was more
like not that i can't put a nail on the
wall
but he just was like really really good
at finding beams and also hanging things
very straight see how did that happen
because my
father can't build anything so that's
why i can't build anything but your
father was a builder so how come where
were you
like when he was building stuff did you
just were you not interested did he not
make you say like sal you're going to
you're going to pick up this hammer
crazy you know you have a parent that
cooks and you become a good cook yeah so
that didn't happen with me
me and my dad are exactly the same and
polar opposites at the same exact right
my dad can build a house from scratch he
was carpenter
right and you know who else was the
carpenter jesus
yeah yeah and we didn't take his name in
vain no no that was his name
not in vain that was positive that was
his name diva
my dad can build a house from scratch
which he has i've watched him like built
put up like erect
yeah like all part of our like he's
freaking michelangelo yeah and then and
then he
he also went to the gym every day for
his entire life i conversely
can't hang a picture frame yeah and i've
never gone to the gym
never a couple times how many times in
your life have you been to the gym
truly um to the gym truly i probably
went
two times for two stints in my life for
one time for about six months to a year
and then one time for about another six
months
got it total and then that's really i
mean that's really i don't know i just
yeah
i mean whatever not everybody is i
should do it i want to do it but i just
i think i'm too old
i don't know i would really have to like
really be it would be
could you imagine if over the next year
i mean sal
got i'm talking about jacked like
ripped and jacked and then you and you
just went but never addressed it you go
back on the show yeah
yeah when i saw that i was like this is
not real he almost looked crazy
yeah i knowed kumail i've known him for
years kumail used to
uh has done when i had the bar back 2008
we had all the comics from this you
probably came over here and did you know
i just i started comedy when you stopped
it
okay because i came in in 2010 yeah and
you were stopping it
yeah so shout out camilla you're a great
guy i i i
but to see his body like that you're
like i don't understand how that how
that well he said on an instagram post
when he first revealed that he was like
he was like that
you have to dedicate your life like it
became his it is his life still his life
i don't want to do that even for a
character in a movie yeah i can't do it
but god bless
i would i got to be honest with you i'm
the kind of guy if you gave me a role
like that in a movie
i would just take steroids i would use
to i would start using hga i would just
be like what if the superhero looks more
like me
right right yeah right yo i'm not a
super hero oh yeah
let's talk about this like yeah does he
have to have abs what if he's had a
similar life experience to me yeah yeah
he's just
anxious yeah he grows his hair out you
that's your superstar that's your
talent you can grow your hair out quick
i can go across i mean hair grow i mean
it's like that you have a pedicure
favorite i've never had a pedicure or a
manicure really never in my life i never
had bologna i did get my eyebrows
threaded though
really is that painful numb i went to
this place ronnie on liberty avenue
in in queens and they were threading it
but no it wasn't painful it's kind of
like they're playing
like the violin on your eyebrows you do
that though i did it once
then the rest of time now i shave it
with the mach3 i just shaved my unibrow
you just shaved your forehead yeah i've
shaved i came in i think one with an
episode i had a dot on my head because i
i
nicked it does that make it like is that
an old wives tale that
if you do that you make it worse i don't
know i mean i just noticed like when it
gets a little bushy yeah
i'll just take a razor and shave the
middle of my eyebrows that's what i'll
do
i had a pedicure for the first time in
my life like a few years ago
right and um we both have horrifying
looking feet
yeah oh really you think you have a nice
looking feet i think i have a nice left
one and a and a 90
nice right one except for the one toe
that took a right turn well when i
hit it on the bed and i broke it i never
got it fixed what's we'll see
for me because i have toes to cross over
each other i'm like
you took them out the back of your feet
right but so but that's my but that's my
thing i don't know my feet are flat
though there's flat as a man though
right i don't mean
i don't need to insult you but if for me
it's like if you if you're you're also
including the arch
you're saying i i have i think i have
pretty nice feet but you just said then
also one of my
toes is still broken to this day yeah
and it's making a nine degree turn i
i feel like that disqualifies you then
all of a sudden you can't have a nice
foot
yeah well that that really does hurt the
right foot right
but if you take if you don't if you
discount that one toe
the foot's pretty good you have nine
beautiful toes yeah right yeah
nice toes you have nine beautiful toes
nice nine toes nice
yeah everything's in order looks nice
again i've got two anything
i have horrifying cue yeah yeah yeah i
know i have horrified feet and actually
my girlfriend
has really bad feet she she admits this
openly and
that was literally the when our daughter
was born the first thing we did was look
at her feet who she got
nobody so far so far so far just regular
feet
no she has no feet she didn't grow yet
no pedicure is a wild thing yeah why
what was wild about it
it feels good and weird at the exact
same time right it feels weird
to sit up on a chair and have a stranger
come in and start handling your feet
like in that manner
um and then i always feel the same thing
i have this phenomenon when i get a
massage if i ever get a massage
never got oh i got one massage my whole
life in hot springs hot springs arkansas
i got a massage from a from a
from a guy who kind of looked like your
dad i'm being dead serious i swear to
god
my dad he looked he looked similar to
your father that's who
who gave you a massage yes all right so
what happened so
well okay so i just want to give a
little little the ancient pedicure
practice of foot care is thought to have
originated
in ancient egypt that's your history
there you go
in the royal palaces of the pharaohs who
were known to take special care of their
legs and feet
it's believed that nobles in ancient
babylon later created luxurious solid
gold tools specifically for manicures
and pedicures it's weird because it's
it's so
intimate and you don't know the person
from a whole wall and i also have this
other phenomenon like i was saying when
i get massages
but you wouldn't know a hole in the wall
yeah i wouldn't know you know what i
mean like
yeah i wouldn't know from a whole yeah i
wouldn't know a hole in the wall either
they wouldn't i don't know what that
saying goes
yeah i don't remember where does it come
from yeah but they start to really get
in there and they start to like push
your cuticles down and right
they hold one toe at a time yeah
things that people i know really well
haven't even done to me
right i know you for years i've never
massaged your toes like that
nail on a specific toe you know and
pushing cuticles down and then
and then they get the thing in there
they've taking off the dead skin and
yeah they're like putting their oils and
then they're filing have you ever had
a toenail filed no i've never i've never
had anybody
it's like nails on a chalkboard to me
it's like because they're like going
and then like the nail is kind of like
pushing around i could feel it in my
butt like i can feel the pain in my butt
yes
that's what it feels like and you're
like oh and you're putting all this
trust in the stranger
and then sometimes they get it they get
in there a little too sharp and you're
like ah
and then they're just like ah sorry and
then you feel weird doing that
yeah it's an experience that if you can
let go might feel well
right i feel good but if you can't let
go you just sit in that tents the whole
time like
it's not really weird well that's their
job but you feel weird
yeah that's the see for me i wouldn't
get a pedicure because to pull out my
how in my opinion it's like how
disrespectful i'm pulling out my bare
foot right now and i'm saying listen
imagine
listen guys yeah oh i could imagine
sometimes
they let you they they give you a bucket
of warm water and it's like has a blue
tint to it maybe it's like a
yeah like a windex or something they
have you put your feet in there for like
a minute
yeah and then that's it that's the only
thing they do
to sanitize you don't know they don't
know what you came from right what
you're working with yeah
imagine you're one of these people that
really doesn't give a hoot about
anything right and they go in there with
an old and crushed elated type of weird
[ __ ] going on
i always never see when the toes look
like they're like like like an
inch thick i always think about that
with doctors
imagine being a urologist or a
gynecologist
some of the genitalia these people are
pulling out who's
could you imagine the genitalia these
people see on a
i sound like sebastian menosco could you
with these people
sebastian if you're watching we'd love
to come on we'd love to get you in the
podcast as long as you have a valid
cover test
yes buddy but who was like who's like i
aced high school
i got a bright future in front of me i
am going to college now i'm trying to
decide what i want to do but i'm
thinking
i want to inspect genitalia for a living
it's only going to take a couple hundred
thousand dollars and seven more years of
training
and then i'll be able to look at
people's problem genitalia areas i'm
looking at everybody's urethras
everybody i think here's what i do know
do you want
take and pimp you look this up after i
say because i'm i'm i i'm
i'm 100 i'm 99
positive when i'm about to tell you is
the truth and i don't know if you would
ever know this
if you had to guess what is the highest
paid
position for a a specialized doctor or
residency
right out of school right out of school
right well i'm sorry right out of their
residency program what is the highest
paid
starting salary doctor do you know
specialty
uh would not we're excluding surgeons
you just mean specialty doctors
specialty doctor no i think even well
yeah especially doctor
what is the highest paid like plastic
surgeons no no
it is is it skin doctor dermatologist
dermatologist
that's number one so i get why people
people yes see look surgeon
dermatologist or
urologist is fourth on the list there's
your answer wow the genitals make money
you know what the least amount of money
you make is unfortunately pediatrician
which should be the highest should be
the highest but they have the littlest
bodies
that's true so that's why that's why you
make the left maybe get paid per inch on
a body
wait so so a dermatologist oh you know
on the on the show we played uh what's
the foot one podiatrist
podiatrist we were podiatrists we've
played every doctor on the show right so
dentists podiatrists and we get into a
real office and then these people come
in and we're
making believe we're the podiatrist so i
was a podiatrist for a day
and the people came in and took their
feet out what did you do
the feet like like you get some stinky
feet dude like
most of the feet were very bad really
very bad and and actually
right in front of him what would you do
well now you can now
the doctor you get numb to it and you
just are like a professional no i've got
people with taking out toes
yeah and feet yeah that if you didn't
tell me it was a foot
i wouldn't be able to identify did i
ever tell you about the time when i was
uh you know getting my doctorate degree
in physical therapy
and i was in anatomy and physiology with
the cadaver i never told you about that
with dr futterman
shout out doctor farman um and uh you
had
oh my god you saw a cadaver saw them are
you kidding me all the time
for a whole summer the summer of 2007
and cold cadaver summer
i don't know what you were doing in
summerville seven i was in the cadaver
lab
at n.y.i.t in old west ferry i was
bartender getting my doctor so yeah you
were bartender i was looking at cadavers
dead bodies
decapitated heads skinned faces there
was this one woman
had pubic hair and her nails painted was
the creepiest thing of all time i
couldn't
what because the cadaver you can you can
disconnect from it when you're like oh
that's just a body but when it has pubes
and it's nails painted you're like
what's
going on oh my god but the craziest
thing is it gets to the point where
literally the day before our final i may
have told the story on another podcast
the day before our final or maybe this
one the day before our final
our final exam for the anatomy final
where you have to
literally go through a cadaver and the
doctor dr fighterman would pin
you know opinion what is this what is
that and you have to just write it down
and go on your own
cadaver or did everybody work on the
same cadet we would all work on that
well there were
there were six or seven cadavers like
you were walking around it like
like it was all over the room and hold
on a second wait a minute what happens
when
where what is the fate of that cadaver
is is it for don't
they donated to medic to medical science
so that you look at it and then but then
how long is that cadaver good for
and then when that cadaver is no no no
no more
use to you what do they do with it i
don't know are these homeless people
or people who don't know anybody if you
put on the back your license
you can donate your body to by the way
here's here's another fun fact
when you put donate your body to science
you can do whatever you want but just
know
if you're like dying on the side of the
road and they see that you're
an organ donor they work a little less
hard does that should save your life
is that what i'm gonna say right now on
hey babe right now it's true wow
yep we're outing them i'm outing what's
that outing though
some people want to know the bodies
exhibit sure i went to that and i heard
that that was controversial because yes
a lot of those people were unidentified
yes and they said maybe they were
homeless people that passed on no no
they were from a chinese prison camp
that's where they got the bodies from i
was in graduate school
that's true though that's true that's
true and so so
they got heat for that yeah they got
heat for that but because i was such a
psychopath at that time already
immune to the cadaver i went with my
girlfriend at the time who wasn't in
graduate who wasn't uh or she was in
graduate school but wasn't working on
the cadavers we went to that bodies
exhibition she like
was like almost like dry heaving because
she was like seeing skin bodies and i
got two slices two sicilians
but so the day before the final i mean
the day be the night of the because we
used to study we still
you know getting the doctor degree we're
like locking ourselves in the libraries
and the cadaver labs like this is real
stuff
we all ordered food we all ordered pasta
and food to the cadaver lab which was
very and i was eating fettuccine alfredo
and i was eating the fettuccine alfredo
going up like i had it next to the body
seinfeld yeah i'm eating the fed
well what do you mean what happened with
science junior mints fell in the well it
was a surgery
they were watching a surgery and a
junior mint fell on the bottom they
sealed them up
oh really yeah but wouldn't it just melt
i mean the heat of the body is 98.93
mint melted yeah yeah um so so
so anyway i'm i'm doing the you know
we're looking over the um
we're looking over the the the body and
going over everything and i'm eating the
fettuccine alfredo nobody saw this i
didn't even see this
a noodle of the fettuccine alfredo fell
into the body
i'll never forget where it was it was in
the pancreas in this place called the
isle of langerhans
that's that's the islets of langerhans
islets of land grants
that's the organ that was pinned and i
the fettuccine alfredo it just blended
into the body dr fudderman had a pin
through the string of fettuccine alfredo
on the pancreas no yes on the pancreas
yeah groups of pancreatic cells eyelets
of langerhans
groups of pancreatic cells yeah
secreting insulin and glucogen
glucagon glucagon what is that it's like
it's like what glucagon glucagon is like
it's like what gives your body energy
it's like glucagon is like
like what gets glue out of a carpet
glucagon yeah yeah it was right by the
pancreas and like the
i think or yeah the the uh makes sense
yeah breakdown of like again to glucose
in the liver yep hormone hormone form i
haven't you know done this in a while
it's not it's not it's not energy it's a
hormone did
was it was it professor fundament what's
his name dr fighterman dr futterman
yeah and one of them like butter
like right or nutter yeah like fudderman
and did he see the fettuccine no he's
the one that pinned it because it was
blended into the body it was my boy
eddie shout out eddie
it was my boy eddie who literally was on
you know was like whatever number 17
and he looked back and he goes and he
looked down and he saw
then that was i was the talk of it they
were like i can't believe he pinned the
fettuccine
right on i would have been i would call
you alfredo after that i know and by the
way i apologize it wasn't the eyelid of
langerhans but shattered i love lager
hands no disrespect to you guys
pancreatic cell is very necessary
it was on the duodenum which is a part
of this that's part of the small
intestine
how do you remember the small intestine
unravel the small ready for another fun
fact mind blowing i'll be ready all
different small intestine
10 times as big as a large intestine you
unravel your small tests right now 25
feet
25 feet if i unraveled all the cells in
your body
i mean i'm talking about all the cells
in organs if i unravel them all go
around the world seven times
just your body that what do you mean if
i your cells are so tightly packed
cells microscopic microscope yeah but
they're so
so if i uncoiled all your organs
arteries blood vessels and cells
yourself
around the earth google it tell me i'm
right
how could that be possible buddy there's
not enough physical space in me
bob bob's i'm telling you because cubic
pimpy one go google one human body cells
go around the world when you unpack them
yep unpacked yeah what what you find out
with pimp is even though he's a master
editor
can't spell for [ __ ] he's bad with
google yeah um
by comparison the circumference of the
earth is 25 000 miles that means a
person's blood vessels can opera on the
planet approximately two and a half
times so i'm sorry you can
two and a half times so so your
circulatory system is extremely long
wait what what human body is [ __ ]
this can't be real go ahead google it
eleven you're
telling me what i'm telling you you're
telling me that my blood vessels will go
62 000 miles if they're stretched out
yes two and a half times earth's 25 000
miles right now
62 and a half thousand miles worth of
blood vessels right in your body right
now how's that possible
because the because our bodies are so
tightly packed the cells in the body are
62
000 miles but i'm five foot ten in
average adult they would stretch for a
hundred thousand miles
a hundred thousand miles babe how far
can the human body stretch
yeah well that's true no no the the the
the yeah the dna the dna and the cells
and everything
that's crazy items highlighted in yellow
are mandatory must
read please feel free to ad-lib the
introduction with a personalized story
or start with the below introduction or
an alternate introduction from page two
wouldn't it be great if there was a
pocket-sized guide that
helped you sleep focus act be
better there is and if you
have 10 minutes headspace can change
your life
next please mention all the talking
points below
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness
in the form of guided meditations in an
easy-to-use
app headspace is one of the only
meditation apps advancements and
meditation through
clinically validated research so
whatever the situation headspace
really can help you feel better
overwhelmed
headspace has a three-minute sos
meditation for you need some help
falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions for the
members swear by
and for parents headspace even
has morning meditations you can do with
your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness
can reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense of
well-being hosts talk about their
experience with headspace
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
six hundred thousand five star reviews
and over 60 million downloads
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice
with mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere
call to action must read you deserve to
feel happier
and headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com
hey babe that's headspace.com
hey babe for a free one-month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every situation
this is the best deal offered right now
head to headspace.com slash hey babe
today
disclaimer failure to read highlighted
items
you know what i was thinking about the
other day how how could i know
and what i wish you would see more of i
love ray j
brandi's brother of course i love this
guy i love i love him
i know his songs yeah i love his music i
love some of the videos he's been in
i love ray j and i just wish i heard
more about him but i haven't seen
anything
from ray j lately have you you nuts are
you
nutso in your head yes he has his own
headphones
icons babies ray cards are from rachel
you don't know nothing about that
i love writing they have wireless
headphones and they they they hook up to
bluetooth nice and easy
they got six hours of playtime yeah
you do know raycon of course i know
raycon i had them in my ears yesterday
you had a pair of recons in your ear
yesterday and didn't know that they were
owned by ray j and today
you brought up ray j on your own i
literally
this morning had my raycon headphones in
was listening to brandy sitting up in my
room sitting here thinking about you
but the reason i was listening that song
is because i want to feel closer to ray
j and i didn't realize
ray j is actually inside of me you ray j
was inside of you like many of
you know ray j was inside your ears yes
like
no no i'm saying like usually he's
inside your ears because of the sonic
right
the sonicness of it but now he's
physically inside you he was
rayjay was physically inside of me
through raycon headphones and i
and all you have to do if you want to
get ray j inside no strings attached
no strings attached literally by
raycon.com
hey babe the website is by byu raycon
r-a-y-c-o-n.com
hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e get ray j inside
you
sal you know who i love who do you love
lucy
the girl from around the way no the
nicotine alternative lucy lucy
yes lucy hello it's a nicotine
alternative
that i found and then i've actually have
i have an aunt you know my aunt colleen
she smokes a lot
and i tried to get her to quit because i
said listen it's 20 20. i mean what are
you doing aliens are out i mean there's
a pandemic
you got to stop smoking i got her on
lucy the woman hasn't smoked in three
weeks is that right the nicotine
alternative she's chewing the gum
you gotta do it now we know too much
about cigarettes and they're not good
for you and here's the thing with gum
normally what do you got two flavors you
gentlemen winter greens you got your
winter green guess what lucy also has
are you ready for this yeah pomegranate
shows me they're innovating i
i told my aunt eileen i said pomegranate
is good for the process she said i'm a
woman i said well i have a low iq
a subscription lucy comes directly to
your door each month it's so simple you
don't have to leave your house
because lucy has delivery down listen
normally
when someone named lucy comes to my
house i've made an illegal transaction
this time it's fine it's legal all you
got to do is go to lucy
dot co that's lucy.co and use the promo
code
hey babe at checkout there you're gonna
get five percent off ten percent fifteen
percent you're getting twenty percent
off what
including the gum and the losses which
is insane now yeah hey
you're giving it away the promo code is
hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
the website is lucy dot co if you put
the m in it
you're making a mistake you're not gonna
get anything it's lucy dot co
promo code hey also i have to give this
disclaimer warning
seriously the product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
and nicotine is an addictive chemical
okay so remember the other day i told
you i said i'm sick and tired of going
to the grocery store i'm not doing any
more there's covert there's lines i
don't want to do it anymore yeah you
were screaming at me
and i said can there be at least one
place that gives me
22 or more fresh recipes and ingredients
it was specific
but i thought it was odd but yeah you
said that well i found it
hellofresh i went to hellofresh.com you
ready for what i did oh i know about
you know about hellofresh what'd you do
i i went to i couldn't believe what this
was was happening i go to hellofresh.com
on a whim i put in the promo code hey
babe 10.
just out of nowhere i said just try
something you know so i go hey babe 10
promo code they gave me 10 free meals
are you paid for shipping i didn't pay
for shipping get out of here i checked
my credit card bill i called i said
there's been fraudulent activity there's
no nobody even charged me for shipping i
got 10 hello fresh meals in here by
using the promo code hey
who's the ceo of hello fresh crazy eddie
that's insane it's santa claus
what are what are even the options for
the food i did look it up okay there's
there's carb smart okay locale
pescatarian vegetarian everything you
want
and it's basically uh they they they
package
fresh produce from from local farmers
from local farmers i mean what else do
you want
they're even following the trends here
yeah and you know what they do they
pre-package the portions and the
ingredients so i'm not over buying i saw
that you have to go to
these big box stores and buy enough for
a month and then it goes away you're
spending too much on your wallet it's
too much waste for the environment
i don't need it this is helping out i
don't need it at all and and and these
little packages they come
and i cook them i've learned finally
learned how to cook i feel safe because
getting delivered right to my door
and i'm telling you i'm telling you i
literally was sitting down it was like
god himself was speaking to me or
herself or they self would speak to me
and they said
do me a favor chris go to hellofresh.com
put in the promo code hey babe 10. and
watch your dreams come true
and they did i got 10 free meals
including free shipping that's a lot
that's a lot of meals if you eat three
meals a day that's like
three meals point one day worth of food
for no for no no cost no cost at all
i don't understand how i don't
understand the business model that's not
for us to decide that's not for us go to
hellofresh.com hey babe10
use code heybabe10 for 10 free meals
including free shipping yeah america's
number
one meal kit that's why
that's why when you really look at the
human body
and you really look at like when you see
it and like when a lot of people see
death and all that stuff like even my
friend who's a doctor you realize that
it can't be the end when you die and
that we are all one and the same in the
universe it has to be
for example dna right i don't know the
exact numbers this is an inexact
number but just for an example our dna
let's say is
zero zero zero one two three right for
example that's a human is zero zero zero
one two three
a pig a pig's dna is zero zero zero zero
zero
one three two so in other words the dna
of a pig and a human
or any animal is so close
that we must be cut from the same
something or other type of thing came
out of the ocean
it's a simulation it's a simulation
that's what i'm saying it's a simulation
i was high the other day
eating magic spoon and i came up with it
i was on the sativia
i got to get you high we did the one we
did cetivia once in nashville i know
or is it saffia sativa sativa and we
were in
aspen we were remember you you got you
remember you were like
i'm not going to take the early flight i
said you probably should snowstorm and
then i got out you have to stay there
for two more days
yeah but that's fun to be stuck in
aspects found only in humans the hyoid
bone is the only bone in the body that
is not connected to any other
i knew that that's right here the throat
bone the hyoid bone is the dead giveaway
when people know you hung yourself when
people know you hung yourself you
you cracked the hyoid bone the horseshoe
that's why that's why when jeffrey when
jeffrey um epstein was
when they said suicide yeah nope no
cracked hired boy
no cracked hyoid born you say that say
that ten times fast
say that hyoid bone no cracked bones no
cracked tired born no cracked hyoid bone
no cracked hyoid bone no cracked hyoid
bone you could do it send us a video
yes hey babe no cracked hyoid bone
say it 10 times fast honestly if you
really do it
we will send you a t-shirt once the
merch is made which you're working on
now there you go boom
um no i know a lot of stuff the the
highest the hot the hardest bone in the
body is in your skull it's called the
petrous bone
harder than almost any substance in the
world peaches bone right here
a lot of people think it's the femur no
petrous bone because
it's hard to break a femur right if you
if you have a broken femur
if you if you're here's the thing if
you're walking around and your femur
breaks
yeah you you might want and you're a
young person you were in an accident
you got to kind of look into that
because that could be a type of bone
cancer or an issue
here's the thing here's what to know a
sho with the human body
what you give up in mobility you gain
with stability and
what you give up with stability you gain
with mobility in other words
your shoulder your shoulder joint is
very mobile but it's not stable you're
always separating your shoulder
so that's how that it's all that's why
give and take that's
and that's what the balance in this game
is in the world man it's like
if things were if this wasn't some type
of simulation in some game
then things would be more fair same with
the hip bone the hip bone is not very
flexible connected to the
thigh bone the thigh bone but it's very
stable so really if you're breaking a
hip
it's either you got into a car accident
or you're very old you have some type of
osteoporosis so wherever you gain
mobility you lose stability and
vice versa so you know when you look at
the human body it's just crazy man
wow it's just crazy crazy stuff you saw
that cadaver the first time you saw it
right
was it easy to remove yourself from that
situation and be like
this is a cadaver or did you go home
like oh my god i just saw like a dead
dude
for me for me i needed to was it fine or
did you it was
fine that was like i didn't love that
what dr
what dr farterman said yeah he said what
the best thing for
you to do is especially for the first
day when we came in we're all like oh my
god everybody says you have to make a
connection
with the body you have to treat it like
it's real so i of course i had sex with
it
right and then and then no i i tried to
make a connection you give it a name
you say like this is my friend i mean i
know your personality
yeah so what did you name your your body
that you did you remember or no yeah
leroy
okay
yeah so you didn't have any issues then
i didn't have any issues no i actually
named it leroy
no i actually did in an anatomy
was i i did relatively because anatomy
is just it's just
anatomy is just memorizing like i at one
point i still may know every single bone
in the human body
i knew every bone is that because you
had to drill that stuff in your head so
much because that was the curriculum and
you needed to remember stuff
is because you have a passion and a
thirst for the knowledge of it and so
your interest is what kept it in your
head because i don't remember
because i have a problem with the way
they teach in school and that's why i
always can't believe
how much how many history facts you
recall right because i at one point or
another i learned history
trying to retain any of it i think it's
the way that they make us
they teach us to like memorize these
things because this is gonna be on the
test and then once you memorize them
they're you don't need to remember them
anymore and you have to memorize
remember and memorize something else
instead of
like teaching in a way that's not about
like
list this name all of this name all of
that
you know how much are you gonna retain
that i got okay so so with history
the reason why that my mother made that
fun like my the history became a love of
mine because my mom we would go to
boston in philadelphia in colonial
american places and like walk on the
freedom trail and
do all that you'd be like oh like you
know we we talk about different history
characters so that came from her and
then when i would get in trouble i think
i may have said this on the podcast
when i would get in trouble yeah like
you know your mom would or your dad
would
would you know you go in your room for
an hour right i would do that too get
grounded but
she would make me say out loud to state
capitals
oh i would have to i would have to keep
reciting the state capitals
when we got through that and then like
i'm serious like if that's why i know
every state capital she would make me
read the encyclopedia and i'm talking
about
really she if i if i tried to like stop
for a second
you would hear continue and she would
so that was the punishment so you like
played ball in the house
and whatever you knew as soon as she was
like christopher yeah and then you were
like saratoga or
santa fe yeah yeah that's right albany
wright
santa fe right saratoga sarasota is what
i meant no but it's tallahassee oh it's
tallahassee saratoga was the turning
point of the american
revolutionary war that's what you're
thinking of okay oh so i'm thinking the
peanut butter shout out sarah together
by the way though shout out to also tom
brady who just won the super bowl shout
out tom
yeah good for you tom yeah winning super
bowl yeah he won the super bowl
bucks versus the chiefs that just
happened and congrats to the chiefs too
for
getting in second place um um no state
i name a state you can name any you can
name every capital you throw them out
you name every press
i can name no presidents i'm not great
at i
i know the pres i know them i know you
know because the other day you dropped
james buchanan on me
15 president united states really the
worst president
in united states history kind of led to
the civil war was a openly gay man if
you check out
if you check out our youtube christy
comedy youtube he was openly gay as he
presided over the office of the
presidency of the united states
never had never had president james
buchanan 15th president
never had uh a wife or first lady
he had a uh but he but the the united
states of america
the the people at that time knew that he
was he was
he he was openly gay that way at that
time they didn't elect him
i can't imagine they elected an openly
gay man back then he wasn't openly gay
because the
the thing is but he was known i mean
andrew johnson i'm sorry andrew jackson
you know andrew jackson ferdinand
jackson
tonight bill he used to call him miss
nancy that was like he would call him to
his face miss nancy they'd be like
yes and he had his alabama senator i
forgot the alabama center's name was his
boyfriend like they would call he he
would call him andrew johns andrew
jackson would call
his friend the alabama center mrs b like
mrs buchanan
really because at that time at that time
in the 1800s that's why history is
cyclical and that's why
sometimes when you see what modern day
stuff what's going on you're like wait
but if you look back in history
james buchanan and at that time in
history when james buchanan was elected
president
you being whatever your sexual
preferences were gay straight
whatever yeah didn't disqualify you at
all from public office they were like
that's
we don't care about that at all wow so
you you would never even think to ask
someone that it'd be like
there's no point in that it'd be like oh
what kind of underwear do you wear
nobody cares
it's only later it's only now is it like
oh what's your sexual preference so we
think that
at times we think you know you're being
progressive by being like
this this and this but if you look back
in history certain things not everything
of course
certain things were actually regressing
were you like oh no no they never
cared about homosexuality in public
office back then that wouldn't even be a
thing they would think of dreaming of
it's only now
do we make it a stink so it's strange
but yeah president james buchanan
reason why worst president is because he
kind of led
to like abraham lincoln then of course
16th president
he has to take over james buchanan's
mess because he left the country in
disarray
with the union and confederacy he was
the one that kind of didn't care
at all james buchanan really didn't care
about you know
preserving the union at all he was like
you might have slaves have slaves i
don't know he's not fighting for
anything it was lincoln had to be come
on guys we gotta like and then you know
the war
how do you remember all this though how
do i don't know i just
i don't know this is just a small little
little nugget
little knockout all the stuff that you
retain yeah but but then like you said
you know i don't know how to say
tumblewear
right you're like like like an idiot
savant i've been called that yeah
because i have crazy knowledge in
certain areas and
none in others yeah same with me dude so
you know oldest capitals which a lot of
people know that yeah
there's only 50 of them yeah so you
could memorize 50 things
sure that's but the bones in the bonds
i'm sure i can just throw one state at
me
vermont
take a guess
i know that you when you say it i'm
gonna know it right away vermont
vermont man
nothing's coming to mind montpelier
no i would have lost my life on that you
would i would have
a lot of people will guess montpelier
never heard of it smallest capital
building in the country montpelier
montpelier state capital
that's right because this isn't this we
go on the road right when we're in
different states
he's like would you mind if we visit the
capitol building and we take
photos of him in front of the capitol
buildings i got 28.
28 so far i got 28 so far i never heard
of mount
montpelier mountain montpelier
montpelier it's uh because because that
because that part of the northeast the
vermont you know it's very close to
canada that's
the company teddy bear company used to
be part of
france that that was that was the the
french kind of used to
own that part the that used to be at
some point was you know
the spectrum of which you know things
about geography and history versus the
gaping hole
in which i don't right that's somewhere
we are
miles apart with i would be in bat if
you named a state
you'd be and i told you everything i
know about that state you would be sh
it would be shock and awe right but how
much i
don't know right i tell you emotional
intelligence is what i have
you have emotional intelligence i was
book smart but only because i memorized
memorize stuff see i there's certain
things that i memorize but i
like to try to if i can learn it and
understand it
yeah i'd rather do that if it takes a
little bit longer but on the same hand
like let's see i know montpelier i know
some facts about geography but i've
never had bologna
so you've lived a fuller life
yeah you got to try bologna at least
once you do not want to
are you not just like i just need to
have a communal experience
what we need to do one day on the
podcast is i gotta have at the same time
i need to be on the list
bologna pork chop go cheese watch the
godfather yeah all at the same time
that patreon patreon which we're gonna
start that's what we will have a full
episode of
first time yeah first can you give me
another state
okay um uh uh i'll give you an easy one
how about um
let me give you these ones how about
california sacramento
there you go okay so you got one you
know okay how about um how about uh
oregon oregon it's not portland
it's not portland but it is can i give
you a hint
it's not portland but it is it it does
share a name with a fun holiday-themed
city
in massachusetts
holiday themed city holiday themed in
the sense of
on this holiday this may be the best
city to go to in the whole country they
probably make it the most fun
there's been movies about it okay is it
salem
it's salem salem oregon is the capital
oh is that
winston-salem up there winston-salem's
in north carolina
okay yeah okay those are the cigarettes
winston and salem winston and salem yeah
yeah yeah i played that you know dwayne
reed too well that's a new york thing
you know between the two streets
how crazy is that downtown yeah broadway
st dwayne reed yep wayne reed
named that that's how they named it yeah
i saw sarah silverman tweet one time a
long long long time ago
i thought it was very funny i remembered
it it's she said
man of all the black people in new york
city dwayne reed has to be the richest
that's a good joke yeah no yeah i um
no i like yeah history and geography are
just things that
when i'm home you know when i'm home
first of all
i love sports i mean i'm wearing a usa
badminton right by the way could you
even if i even
what is badminton i know what baby
because i i don't even know if i knew
the
like if you put out badminton equipment
i wouldn't guess at that what sport that
is yeah well it's a the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] is it the [ __ ] is it a [ __ ] i
wasn't going to guess [ __ ] but
oh that that that little [ __ ] it's in
it's the rackets and then that thing's
called
can you google usb
but that's the difference if you if you
lose the word shuttle
no but it was a car it was shuttle [ __ ]
that's the ball
right and it's is it two on two yeah
no i don't know i have the sweatshirt
but i don't know a badminton i think
they
whip i think they like whip that thing
do they whip it
they whip it good whip it good yeah devo
sure
devo do you know devo whip it whip it
good
that was the most commercial hit yet
right do you know what devo
stands for div di short for something
d-i-v-o d-e-v-o d-vo devotion
good guess yeah d evolution
wow interesting they were like pretty up
on that [ __ ] devo i really like devo
i know some of the deeper cuts i i got
in i got into t
i don't even know just a funny thing
just a devo break is great
yeah yeah i mean devo if you want can
they come on uh
you know it was in devo mark mother's
bar who's that mother's bar as a
musician
uh mother's bar yeah mother's bar
or bar um m-o-t-h-e-r-s
i think mark mother's bar lost mother's
body
mark and bob see yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah and they later went on to make
a lot of insane great music they do most
of the music
in all of the um uh what's his name uh
wes anderson movies wow yeah he does
shauna freddy krueger yeah
freddy krueger isn't oh that's wes
craven
no wes anderson is like um royal tenon
bombs uh
never seen it okay all right but you
know you know
uh the hotel the great amazing movie
the shining no no no no the um what's
the name of that movie
how can i not remember this uh moonrise
king
grand budapest hotel grand budapest and
of course no i've never seen it and of
course uh
you know you know what it's the grand
budapest hotel
an amazing amazing movie fantastic mr
fox
but what's the one with uh what's the
best one it's one of my favorite movies
ever and i'm blanking on it
um um not not not not uh
royal tennis bombs steve no not
steve zizu isn't live aquatic no though
his main one it's
uh holy [ __ ] hotel chevalier isle of
dogs
moonrise kingdom rushmore
oh my god it's a rush war is amazing
bill murray
no i've never seen any of this the only
bill murray i've ever seen is groundhog
day
really oh and ghostbusters yeah you
gotta you gotta you gotta watch these
i know i gotta start watching it i got
all right but how do we get from devo
you want me to
how about one more state yeah please
okay do it um you want it a hard one or
an easy one or they all come in
badminton yeah bad badminton
badminton i thought it was bad i thought
it was badminton badminton
like am i badminton badminton it's
badminton it's badminton
fancy a game of badminton a vitamin i
wanted to start playing backgammon
have you played that no what's this
batman and backgammon you know what
backgammon is
back home is where they come to your
house they come to your house like i
love the suitcase
it's like a it's a game inside a
suitcase i'm not even joking
there's like dice and chips and yeah
see that you open up the suitcase so
there's a national
no you've seen that never seen that in
my life i've heard of backgammon that's
it but i've never seen again i
there's a lot of things in my life like
i've heard of these things i don't know
what they are i was younger my stepmom
used to
play backgammon a lot and and i think it
was way more popular popular back then
and i i never learned how to play and i
always wanted to and
just recently i was like i'm gonna learn
how to play backgammon by the way
speaking of steph
what what what is with st you know i
know it sounds like a seinfeld thing but
it's like with step
what does that mean what's the deal step
mom step down step
step i don't know why side mom's side
dad so that sounds like
what's worse all right so let's stick
with what's up half no
i don't know second mom second second
they should do that
how about this
homage homage how about this you ready
let's keep it with french-themed
name state capitals okay and montpelier
the french french named uh
after vermont very common french
name also the capital of south dakota
what is it
pierre that's it uh see you
you got two out of three i knew that one
well you with the hints i knew it
i would have said jacques i wouldn't
have remembered it what about jacques
south dakota francois south dakota okay
pick pierre
yeah pink panther south dakota
you picked the french name did you ever
go to mount rushmore no but that's in
south dakota i never did either but you
know what's weird you have to go to
patreon
patreon it's it will it'll be a frolic
session we're going
did you ever go to the alamo yes isn't
it weird how the animals like
like if when you when you're there and
you look it's just on a regular street
like a starbucks across the street yeah
right across street there's a there's a
ripley's believe it or not
there's people when you see like
pee-wee's big adventure in the movies or
like
the movies it's well the movies like
historically they don't have that there
but
you never realize that it's just and i
think i think mount rushmore is like
i think there's like a target across the
street well that's like the egyptian
pyramids andrew schultz went out to the
different pyramids he's like there's a
pizza
across the street yeah no the alamo the
alamo
alamo has by the way the alamo has forty
thousand two hundred reviews
four point six stars we are not
remembering the elements
i told you right there it's right across
the street there's a hyatt
shout out to san antonio um um so funny
that people are just like oh my god the
alamo
five stars no yeah but then some people
like i didn't like it that much i don't
know what to tell you the alamo
see that part of history you know let's
see how much
what ripley's rating is please believe
it or not can you imagine ripley's has a
higher rate
4.4
[Laughter]
only 2.2 below let's see yeah
wow 4.3 let's see what the here go
scroll out a little bit
let's see what the um uh yeah let's see
dick's last resort which is
walking just from the alamo scroll in a
little bit there you go let's see what
dick's last resort got
4.1 by san antonio city riverwalk
great it's great dude i stepped in human
[ __ ] on the street there you know what
happened to me
cockroach that big tried to attack me
were you doing shows out there were you
visiting
i was doing shows and i was staying in a
hotel on the riverwalk right and we went
in it was like a historic hotel and it
had a real like
new mexico type of vibe it was cool but
it smelled weird it was like old and
very musty
right i checked into my room i felt it
had a very musty smell
i think i told this on the podcast i
don't know no i i i had i have a sixth
sense
when it comes to like you know like i
don't know what you would call like
gaydar for like bugs
right that's what you have though i mean
you had 300 dead flies yeah
you have bug yeah right so like i went i
checked in and i said
i feel like i'm gonna come across some
type of bug in this hotel
right and i came back from my shows and
i went to go to bed and i really felt
uncomfortable in this hotel
and so what i decided to do was no joke
because i had the cpap machine
i wrapped myself up like a burrito if
you will like a cocoon
because i didn't want any penetration
from you know from
and i went to bed and i dreamt that
night and i've told this story before
but i swear to god
i had a vivid dream that a huge
roach this big like just were coming at
me
they came into the walls and they were
trying to get into the blankets and i
kept on waking up in the middle of night
looking and just tucked
myself back in right and i was sweating
under there but i just wouldn't
compromise the the the
i didn't i knew there was gonna be a
goddamn roach yeah i woke up in the
morning
i dreamt of roaches cockroaches all
night okay and then
i got out of bed and we had to leave for
the next city and i went i went to take
a shower
and i went to the bathroom and i my
toiletry bag was on the sink
right and i went to move my toiletry bag
and i moved it this big a roach this big
on the kitchen uh the the bathroom
counter of the sink
that big i let out a i literally helped
yelp
it had to be like just a young
a young young girl yeah like a young
girl i was like
a yelp yeah and and i freaked
out and i took one of the glasses and i
put it over the roach wow
and i and i just walked out didn't even
brush my teeth
i didn't do anything i put everything in
my suitcase and i walked out and i
walked out to the
the van that we had waiting to bring us
and i just got shot in the next place i
i brought that roach i it was like the
book the secret
yeah i put it out into the universe i
brought it and came right back what are
the odds that i walk in and i go i feel
that this is gonna be a bug here
i feel it's gonna be a cockroach i dream
of cockroaches all night
i can't have to go brush my teeth and
there's a cockroach this big in the room
so i just have some type of power i just
told you if i uncoiled your body you'd
wrap around the earth seven times
i think you can smell a bug coming yeah
you know what i mean
i knew it it was there it freaked me out
you freaked a dude it would freak me out
zero stars
zero yeah zero stars for that hotel i
you know i have an um
uh an uncle who fought in vietnam and he
told a story
that he was eating they would send them
beans like you know cans of bean or what
you know
one of the foods they would give is
beans to the army
and he was in the army and he was eating
the the the can of beans
and he says to the guy next to him you
know he told the story obviously or told
my aunt the story and then she told it
when we got older
that he was like oh he's like i'm eating
the can of beans like right there in
vietnam
and he goes i say to my friend he was
like it's these
these this is so much better with meat
in it finally and he's like there's no
meat in mine and he looks and he was
eating a roach
he was eating a roach with the beans but
you know he was like whatever it's
protein you need to do you could do it
go to vietnam if you're a factor you eat
a bug
no i couldn't do that if if if you were
on television and money was on the line
like would they win 50 grand on fee
factor or something like that yeah could
you eat one bug
just pick up a cockroach and eat it by
the way ari's
ari ahri's out of the country and he's
in like the amazon right now right i
don't know if i'm giving anything away i
doubt it
but uh he's he sends me pictures of him
eating bugs all the time and it's
disgusting it's disgusting i can't do it
yeah
for me yeah that was sorry that's crazy
he's ordering bugs at restaurants yeah
because you can eat that well that was a
delicacy eating crickets was a delicacy
in ancient times what will it take
there's a dollar amount for you to eat a
bug
for me to eat a bug fifty thousand
dollars on fairfax i guess for me
it depends what the price of bitcoin is
at the time i do it i
i mean i do it for three bitcoins
whatever that is what what would happen
would you would you just vomit
would you is that your favorite word for
throwing up vomiting what's your
favorite uh
synonym for throw up i say puke a lot i
just i say
i know a lot of people think puke is
gross i say pew it's funny how you could
think puke is gross
and vomit is gross but throw up is the
same exact thing but not gross you know
what i think is the
most disgusting word in the human
language and it excuse me not even to
say it
moist feet feet feet you're ready to do
it oh
chills when you said it feet it didn't
give me the heat even even if you're
like oh look how gorgeous that woman's
feet are as soon as i think about as
soon as you say feet i'm out
feet i don't want to know about your
feet yeah feet puke what's some other
words for vomit put you on your lunch
and take a peek moist
phlegm ointment panties lugibrius
[Laughter]
uh montana helene i didn't know that
yeah
although i now know what how you say it
helena i should say not helene helena's
a woman i oh i thought it was helena
hallelujah it's helena montana it's
helena montana i think it's
it's either helena it's either it's
either helena
is the capital of montana or she used to
be my lunch monitor when i was a kid
helena nice all right helena montana
phlegm pant you've been a montana third
world dollop
dollop is what that's a state shout out
to donald podcast that's a good podcast
helena have you ever been in the state
of montana you know i don't think i have
i think it's one of the
i think it's the only wait i can't
remember
you know you ever go through that no
i've never been on my town i've never
been to montana in alabama i think
there's two states
i have not played in what i think
montana is one of them what's the other
one i think it's one of the dakotas
right i think but you've been in you
don't remember which dakota you've been
to but i did play wyoming i think
you know the capital that one is
beautiful name cheyenne cheyenne
cheyenne which a lot of people name
their kid cheyenne you've heard of that
name cheyenne cheyenne wyoming speaking
of kids
we did you're having one
let's bring them out again
speaking of kids we put out a video a
couple of weeks ago
where we shattered this child's guinness
book of world war i being shattered
yeah by four seconds which when guinness
times
you're talking like it's like the
olympics point means
one second is a lot right it's a you
know before seconds is a world right a
world apart
you shattered it shattered we did it
without thinking we did it on the fly
right we challenged everybody to hashtag
hey babe guinness book
and send us back and people demolished
us
demolished i mean we beat the kid by
four seconds and then me and you were
like high-fiving
laughing and pushing each other into the
bushes yeah people beat you by 15
seconds 15
20 seconds [ __ ] it into 30 seconds by
the way and some
and a lot of people did it the right way
but there's some people who just started
counting the whole point of this thing
is you have to be on somebody's
shoulders
i know but then some people look at this
i mean this is a damn
mark a uh at skc you
dog he did let's go he's on his
daughter's shoulder
he he's this is a man that is three
times the size of his daughter
he's 220 pounds yeah while the dog is
licking his
dog to the 100 second chance okay
well you gotta you gotta i'm not on
i mean the dog is biting his kid's face
also how is she
holding that man ready one two three
four five
six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20
21 22 to 3 12 over 25
28 29 30 31 32 34 40 36 73 39 40 41 42
42 33 44 444
40 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 99 100. wow
38 seconds it was like 37 that dude and
you know what happened though i realized
what happened you went
long on your nines i'm in the nines i
said i i thought i
turned into like a horse racing sir so
should we try to redeem it if i'm
thinking
ten nines like that nine cost you at
least 10 seconds
it did and everybody i mean
everybody just shellacked us why don't
why don't we do it again
you get on my shoulder should we do it
let's do it should we do it
do we know what the time to beat is
i saw a lot of like mid 30s mid 30s
see what we got going let's do it all
right might as well want to go out like
this
might as well okay we're trying to be
let's just say we're trying to be 35
seconds okay
oh my god that's so hard you ready okay
let's do it sal tonight you got you
count me down from
three three two one go let me know when
you're ready bud
okay you ready get your shuttlecock in
position okay
all right let me know let me drink some
water
here it is okay
all right
you're good i have to make sure i don't
go nine
yeah the goal is 35 seconds here ready
okay you count me down so you say three
two one go
are you ready right now yeah all right
three two one
go one
fifty six seven eight nine sixty six one
six two six three six four six five six
six
seven six six six nine seventy seven one
seven two seven three seven four seven
five seven six seven seven
seventy seven seven eight seven nine
eighty eighty one eight twenty three
forty five to six seven eight
nine ninety ninety one ninety two ninety
three ninety four ninety five six seven
eight seven eight 5967989 100.
29.69 seconds 4.69
we brought 30 seconds
absolutely you can see my other podcast
christy chaos christy comedy.com
check me out 29 seconds check out taste
buds also on the no
crush network absolutely we got merch
coming soon
for both shows hey check out paycheck
coming soon merch that's 29 29.69
seconds i got a patreon patreon.com
christy comedy
check out the impractical jokers are out
with season nine
should people redo it yeah 29.69 seconds
redoing it seconds off what's the time
try it we dare you to try it
dare you to come at us come at us
hashtag
absolutely drink your
a flake don't whiskey away from your
feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe